what attracts you to a good pitch
because some people say I can make a
decision in three seconds by the way the
person walks in the door they're opening
sentence I do that for hires not for
pitches now when it comes to hires I can
make a decision in three minutes not
three seconds but three three minutes
okay um when it comes to pitches the one
thing that really sticks out to me is
are you doing this because it's a big
white space and it's just like oh it's
open and you know nobody's doing it or
is there a real story is there a
connection and I found out when there's
a connection then people actually tend
to stay in the business longer and they
still they tend to want to do better and
they don't just stop and they don't give
up when times get tough when there's a
market downturn like what we're dealing
with now
um they keep going